As you see in the algorithm for finding the first match was a bit more
involved, and it looks like our friendly Udacians
have given us some more starter code. We have an integer index that starts
at zero. We have a boolean variable to keep track of whether we already found a
match. Now, we have to keep looking while what? First of all, while we haven't
yet found a match, and while we'll still have a chance of finding one. Now I is
the index. We need the actual picture at that index. Here it is. We need to
check whether it's a match. It's a match if it's taller than it is wide. Now if
it is a match, then we set found to true. Otherwise, we keep on looking at the
next position. Finally, if we have found a match, then we need to draw it.
Where do we find it? Well, at position I. So we get it from here. When you run
the program, it shows the first match. It happens to be this one. It might be
nice to know what all the matches are. And as it turns out, that's actually
easier to do then finding the first one. Let's see how to do that.